okay so we are back with kang only
myself left to conquer part four god i
love this story okay so where we left
off in the last video is that basically
uh nathaniel had been really sent to the
40th century now there's a big
difference here in terms of the origin
of kang as we know it and the origin of
kang as it's being retold here so one of
the things that goes on here and
it's really kind of marvel giving us
that older origin in a familiar way but
changing it up so in earth and in the
40th century as the way that you're
seeing this play out where it's quote
unquote ramatat who ends up in the 40th
century that's technically accurate
that's the way it played out in comics
originally when it came to kane the
conqueror the difference here is that
this version of rama tut is not the same
as the way it was originally done in
marvel comics since the reason why we're
getting this change in origin that rama
tut was the tried and true kang
operating under the guise of rama tut he
was ultimately defeated by the fantastic
four fled back to his era ended up in
the 40th century and so in in the way
the comics were originally told it was
basically a different version of ramadan
than the one that we see here right
nathaniel his motivation for why he did
what he did when he was ramitah was
totally different him operating as rama
tut here now in the 40th century is
different but again it's marvel
basically solidifying that no matter
what nathaniel does he will always
become king and he'll always follow the
path of the person that ends up becoming
king that is unavoidable and there's no
way to escape it the way we know this is
that when he shows up here what he finds
himself in is basically a war-torn
territory now one of the big differences
here is that in the original stories the
way it was told by rama tut right so
avengers 269 captain america annual
number 11. ravana ren slayer didn't
exist or at least she wasn't there when
he appeared in the 40th century not the
way that she is here so again it's
marvel just kind of shifting things
around and really retelling the origin
of ravana which really kind of begs the
question is kang volume 1 a retelling of
king's origin or a reworking of ravana
right like if you had to pick one as the
main focus of the story which one would
it be i mean technically it's both but
which one does it lean more towards i
guess is the more accurate question to
ask but when he shows up here of course
immediately being met by ravana the the
whole idea behind life in this future is
that it's very harsh right it is a very
harsh and just a battle-hardened life
and more often than not in marvel comics
that's how the future is depicted to us
it's given to us in different ways but
the future is shown as a very hard and
bleak and dark place right days of
future past the era of apocalypse in the
far-flung future right when apocalypse
rules the world this era of kang like
all these different things right it's a
very harsh and difficult place to be in
right new canaanites versus the chosen
or the clanacaba or whatever it is it's
always that kind of thing right so it's
really interesting to see that marvel
sort of keeps this maintained but
against these forces what you have here
is ravana renslayer leading by all
standards of measurement a primitive
race for the most part that there are
weapons and arms and armament here but
because of because of the fact the
society as it existed at the time had
effectively collapsed these arms and
armaments are beyond ravana rensselaer
and her people's ability to understand
they can use them to a degree but they
can't use them to their fullest
potential and so what's really cool is
that as the two of them fight together
much like what we saw in their initial
appearances in ancient egypt they fall
in love just like they did before that
their love is born and bred in conflict
just like it was before and the two of
them working as a group face off against
the these barbarian hordes just like
they did before the big difference here
though is that what you have is this
point where once these forces are
defeated again though the world's not
saved so to speak it's just this kind of
immediate battle that what you have is
that with these forces essentially
defeated that nathaniel tells ravana
like you're like like you're amazing and
and i love you the thing about this
though is that he always speaks of a
time in which they'd known each other in
the past she doesn't know him she's as
far as she's concerned she's never met
him so what he's trying to do is he's
trying to kind of continue on the life
they could have had with a person who
knows nothing of that life right as far
as she's concerned in the way that she
feels he feels like he's losing her and
he's pushing you know forcing himself on
her and she's rebuking him in that way
right i mean she she's growing to care
about him but he's basically moving too
hard too fast and as a result of that he
basically tells her like we can leave
this place right like like together we
can leave we can leave this life behind
and we can go to a place where we can
live a glorious life and when he gives
her that revelation she immediately
turns against it now there's a few
different reasons as to why she turns
against it and turns against him the
first is because this is the only life
she knows it's the only life that she's
even willing to accept she can't imagine
a life where there is no such thing as
conflict or war or anything along those
lines but the bigger idea behind this is
that because of the life that she's
lived she's grown to become ridiculously
independent and doesn't see herself as
somebody that can be claimed by any
person and the idea of nathaniel showing
up here using what is in effect an
archaic standard of love and connection
and saying that like you're my girl we
knew each other in the past right you
don't know me now but you can know me
again i'm gonna take you away from this
place it almost puts her in a feeling of
being subservient which is something
that she immediately regrets and so in
doing so that's what she says like you
would you would tell me that you knew me
in the past right she says all this
power that you have you used to claim me
as you claim this woman that you loved
except that she is not me and i am not
yours i belong to myself and the moment
that we've made this moment we've had
here will be our last you will never see
me again and she leaves and so in
essence and that's what's kind of cool
here is that the way ravana red slayer
is depicted here these different
instances where she appears in the life
of nathaniel and then he loses her
that's designed to mirror the
appearances of ravana red slayer in the
life of kane the conqueror the
difference is that in those lives it was
usually her being betrayed and her being
killed in front of kang or something
along those lines but regardless no
matter how the circumstance played out
it was each one of them losing the woman
they loved and in losing the woman they
loved ultimately where kang saw that as
a weakness nathaniel sees it as how it
is that he becomes king and so that's
why he says he kind of reiterates the
words that were told to him by king
never love and he says as if it were a
choice and then he just kind of steps
into everything right he accepts his
role and he says fine if the choice was
to be mine between a heart pierced by
her gaze and one hardened against her
then i would choose conquest like in
effect he's tired of losing her right
he's tired of experiencing all this loss
and all this pain over and over and over
again and so what he says is my army was
unwashed untrained savage and cruel but
one fact is true throughout time slaves
will become slavers when given a chance
to hold the whip and he says ravana was
incorrect my mind was my greatest tool
for the weapons of war left behind by
those magic fools in her stories were
made of the very technology i had
trained to repair in those long and
listless childhood days complexity had
worn on me he says i wish for something
simple and so i offered all the simplest
choice join me or die many chose death
and so what this means is that he goes
forward literally as a conqueror that he
starts to build this suit up for himself
that basically looks like the suit of
king the conqueror that much like cain
the conqueror he starts to conquer the
world and then once he gets bored
conquering earth he sets his sights out
on the entirety of the galaxy itself
right and then the universe and over and
over and over again taking his forces
with him he conquers everyone and it's
so cool because he says my 100 year
conquest had begun he says what had once
seemed so distant so esoteric so
impossibly vast was now within reach i
needed only wait and watch the 40th
century fall before me but i was not a
man of patience and with my timeship
reforged all of reality awaited my rule
should i have sat surrounded by the
ghosts of lost loves pondering how i
might learn from them or indulge my
glory across the fabric of space-time to
nathaniel it may have been a quandary to
kang it was no choice at all and so he
says to ground the kings of the past to
dust arthur most of all his cries were
not those of a hero but of a child who
thought destiny would not be swayed
against him the cosmosian monarchs
believed themselves safe in their
quantum dimension i showed them the
error of their ways then blessed their
endless cities by reforging them as
factories for my time-spanning war
machine over and over and over again
it's the exact same way he meets
immortus he defeats immortus he meets
the scrolls he defeats the scrolls the
badoon the shiar literally the entire
universe is conquered by king that
nathaniel and that's what's so crazy
here that were kang like the king that
initially appeared saw love as weakness
nathaniel sees it as strength not in the
sense that it's his love for ravana
rinslayer that makes him the person that
he wants to become but ultimately it was
the losing of love of ravana ren slayer
that drove him to become the person that
he is and so ultimately he says once all
of this was said and done at the end of
the day i still never found anything i
still couldn't feel anything i had
conquered the entirety of the universe
and yet something was still missing from
my life something that i felt like i
needed that i wanted i simply just
couldn't find anymore and so what he
does is he travels back to earth after
hearing that there is a single kingdom
out there that remains unconquered by
his forces and so ultimately when he
arrives here that he ends up finding
that this is the last free kingdom
that's ruled by ravana rinslayer now
this it's been quite some time since the
ravana renaissance he immediately met
and in fact he even comments on that he
was like okay it was her it was ravana
red slayer yet again right a different
face but those same eyes and so what
this seems to hit at is that ravana
rimslayer is in a lot of ways a concept
an ideology i mean she is a person but
the big question that has to be asked
here which we'll actually find out
really in the next video
is how it is that ravana rensselaer
keeps reappearing as different people in
the time stream right how is it that in
the days of ancient egypt she had
appeared albeit not necessarily uh as
the ravana rinse slayer that we're
familiar with she shows up in the
moderator really about 100 years ago in
the 40th century and then she shows up
again here and each time she seemingly
looks different how does that happen but
the reality here is that when he does
appear to ravana red slayer the first
thing he wants to do is win her heart
right the first thing he wants is to
have his girl back but the reality here
is she sees him as a conqueror she
doesn't see him as a person she could
love she sees him as a person that she
absolutely hates and so what he realizes
is that the only way to get ravana
renslayer the only way to get her love
is to show her who he really is because
the reality here and this is one of the
best things about this story king the
conqueror as you see him here he's not
genuinely that guy but nathanael is not
genuinely some warlord that wants to
conquer all of existence for no other
reason the fact that it feeds his ego
what he's what he wants is to find some
measure of meaning out there what he's
doing here by conquering everything is
filling the hole in his heart that was
left by not having ravana renslayer but
who he is at his core is a genuinely
great person right it's a genuinely good
guy and that's when he realizes i have
to actually show her who i am in order
for her to truly love me and that's what
he starts doing right that's literally
what he starts doing is he starts
basically operating as effectively a
hero right that he calls off the attack
on her kingdom and then he frees her
kingdom and says like you do your thing
right like your kingdom is totally like
we are hands off not only that he
basically allies himself as heroes right
the ones that were essentially time
displaced but he add he acts as heroes
all the while his general right voltage
is plotting against him and so there
comes a point where in reality the idea
of ravana renaissance slayer as she
appears here being killed does happen at
the hands of baltac right it does happen
as him who ultimately does shoot her and
so basically taking him out as the
traitor saves the life or seems to save
the life of ravana redslayer and so
ultimately he wins her heart right he
finally gets ravana rin slayer's love
and in that moment baltag shoots her
right in the moment when he basically
reveals his role as a traitor before
kang can act ravana rinslayer is killed
and so that's it's one of the the
coolest moments here right he says i
prepare to end bow tag as kang never had
but for a moment i stay my hand for i
have fallen in love and it has not
conquered me it is my mercy she has
grown to love i win and time lapse
because once she's dead and gone it's
the thing where she says maybe it was
just never meant to be maybe we were
just never meant to be together and kang
basically almost breaks on this personal
level right the one chance he had to
finally have ravana ren slayer the
closest he ever got to having the woman
of his dreams and is yanked away it's
pulled away because in reality kang and
kang can never have ravana rin slayer
right it's the the torment of him as a
person he will never get ravana he will
never be in love with ravana he will
never have the life he wants with ravana
that's never going to happen and so what
he does and this basically goes into how
it is that ren slayer appears across the
time stream and he says and so it was
then that i devised a new escape my love
one the old man could never have
accomplished one that i know i already
will he spent the next 50 years mourning
you when you initially died he says in
his time right kang's time he spent the
next 50 years mourning you trying to
bring you his ravana back but i have
seen your face in the distant past and i
have seen your face only a hundred years
ago and i see you here now and where he
was told never loved he says i have
already seen the ripples in the waters
of time but i remained so ignorant as to
the impact that caused them but i know
now what else could it be i am the
impact and i shall shatter time for you
awake ravana awake one 000 times and be
saved by my final conquest and so the
goal of kane the conqueror is to quite
literally shoot ravana red slayer's
essence into the time stream and
basically use that as a way to find a
reality where he can have ravana wren
slayer back so it's really cool right
again it's as much a retelling as
keeping components of the original
origin of king intact i mean i would
surmise all this is being done because
of kang and the marvel cinematic
universe but it's really cool but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace